(upbeat music)
- Not all lawyers are good.
I cannot emphasize this enough,
and not all lawsuits are well stated.
That is doubly true.
And while you have a constitutional
right to a jury trial,
I have a first amendment right
to make fun of you mercilessly
in front of millions of subscribers.
(man laughs)
Now in fairness,
frivolous lawsuits are often brought
by self-represented individuals
who are unable to find a lawyer
to take their crazy cases.
But sometimes there are actual attorneys
who are willing to attach their names
and reputations to the lawsuits
that we're going to destroy today.
So let's start with the
case of the candy box
that has too much air in it.
A time honored tradition
of going to the movies,
is buying movie candy
and one of the more popular movie candies
for inexplicable reasons, is Junior Mints,
the candy that tastes
like you just went to the dentist office.
Now, if you've ever picked
up a box of Junior Mints,
you might have noticed that
the box is not exactly filled
to the top with candy.
For many, this is an irritating example
of shrinkflation
where companies downsize
the size or quantity
of the product that you receive
while charging the same amount of money.
And if you've ever gone
to a movie theater,
you're being charged way, way too much
for basically mint flavored wax.
But for New York City
resident Biola Daniel,
the air in the Junior Mint's
package was an egregious fraud
perpetrated upon the American public.
And for that injustice,
Ms. Daniel and her lawyers
decided to take a stand
for consumers everywhere.
So in 2017, Ms. Daniel
filed a class action lawsuit
against Tutsi Role Industries,
the parent company of Junior Mints,
claiming the manufacturer
intentionally tricks customers
by packaging their candies
in unexpectedly large boxes
topped with too much air,
referred to in the
complaint as slack fill.
- [Man] So as I move this up and down,
it's gonna pump air out of the jar.
- Abel Durin of New York
and Tequila Perkins of Mississippi
but later join the lawsuit
as class plaintiffs.
According to the 36 page complaint,
Ms. Daniel purchased a 3.5
ounce box of Junior Mints
from a local pharmacy for $1.49.
Ms. Daniel complained that the box
"Contained approximately
40% nonfunctional slack fill
while competitor candies like
Milk Duds and Good and Plenty
only contained 23 and 12%
slack fill respectively.
In addition to those candies
actually being something
a human should consume.
The complaint said, "The
science of the products boxes
in comparison to the volume of
the candy contained therein,
makes it appear to
plaintiff and class members
that they are buying more than
what is actually being sold.
Plaintiff and class members
are denied the benefit
of their bargain
because they pay for a
full box of the product
but actually received far less."
But US District Judge
Naomi Reese Buchwald,
disagreed tossing the
complaint 10 months later.
In her 44 page ruling dripping with shade,
Judge Buchwald determined
that there was no fraud
in Junior Mints packaging
and ripped the plaintiffs for claiming
that they had been intentionally
deceived by slack fill.
The judge argued that
there was no deception
because reasonable consumers
of ordinary intelligence,
could have determined
the amount of the candies
from reading the box.
"The law simply does not provide the level
of coddling the plaintiffs seek,
assuming that a reasonable consumer
might ignore the evidence
plainly before him,
attributes to consumers
a level of stupidity
that the court cannot countenance."
And according to Reuters,
hundreds of slack fill lawsuits
have been filed in recent years.
And in the last decade alone,
Tutsi Roll LLC has faced
five separate lawsuits
over air in its candy boxes
with judges in California
New York, Illinois, and New Jersey,
all dismissing these cases.
Now, to be fair to the
class plaintiffs here,
it's not impossible to win these lawsuits.
According to the FDA,
a container that does
not allow the consumer
to fully view its contents,
shall be considered to be
filled as to be misleading
if it contains nonfunctional slack fill.
Slack fill is the difference
between the actual
capacity of the container
and the volume of product
contained they're in.
And the slack fill is nonfunctional
if it is filled to less the capacity
for reasons other than one,
the protection of the
contents of the package.
Two, the requirements of the machines used
for enclosing the
contents in such package.
Three, unavoidable product settling
during shipping and handling.
Four, the need for the package
to perform a specific function.
Five, the fact that the product consists
of a food packaged in a reusable container
or six, the inability to
increase level of fill
or to further reduce
the size of the package.
But under these circumstances,
it looks like these judges have determined
that slack-fill lawsuits
are full of hot air, get it?
Am I right?
(people booing)
Okay, fine, boo me for my amazing puns.
I can hear you through the computer.
But that takes us to
the Minnesota magician
who sued David Copperfield and David Blain
for stealing his godly powers.
- [Man 2] Hell yeah, I
have the power of God.
(tractor engine roars)
- Now, you've probably heard
that he off repeated Axiom,
that people who choose to
represent themselves in court,
well, they have a fool for a client.
But enter Christopher Roller,
a Minnesota magician who decided
that he would also be that fool
by repeatedly suing famous
magician David Copperfield
for millions of dollars.
On what grounds you may ask?
Well, for stealing Roller's
godlike magician powers
without just compensation?
Obviously, now the saga
began in March of 2005
when Roller sued David Copperfield
in Minnesota Federal court.
"David Copperfield has
been using my godly powers
to perform his magic."
The complaint begins
before directing the court
to his website, so it may witness Rollers,
"Journey to godliness."
Citing UFO videos as proof
that godly powers exist on earth.
Roller argues that magicians
including Copperfield,
"Have also been granted
Godly powers by me somehow,
but they have been keeping it as secret
and keeping the credits from me."
Roller who claims he's been
secretly filmed for decades,
all of the "Truman Show."
- Good afternoon, good
evening, and good night.
- Is an avid conspiracy theorist
if you didn't guess that already
with a history of filing
bizarre frivolous lawsuits
like in 2007 when he sued
then President George W. Bush
and Vice President Dick Chaney,
for conspiring with, "Fellow
demons to have roller murdered
with an explosive vice at a red lobster."
In Roller's complaint,
he graciously gives Copperfield
a way out of the litigation
to reveal his magician secrets
that prove Copperfield's tricks/illusions
are done conventionally
and without godly powers.
But Roller lamented that he has,
"Politely asked David via email
to show how his tricks are
done with no response."
I guess Mr. Copperfield
just doesn't have time
for Roller's tricks.
- I Don't have time for your magic tricks.
- Illusions dad, you don't
have time for my illusion.
- Now, Roller who has never worked
for Copperfield in any capacity,
claimed the magician had
violated Minnesota labor law
by stealing his magic,
thus entirely roller to
a modest $50 million,
10% of all past/future career earnings.
And in 2006, the Minnesota Court
summarily dismissed Roller's case
for failure to state a claim.
But believe it or not,
Roller saga against David
Copperfield actually gets weirder.
In June of 2005,
Roller attempted to
patent his magic powers.
In his patent application,
Roller refers to himself as a,
"godly entity who seeks
the exclusive right
to the ethical use and financial gain
in the use of godly
powers on planet Earth."
Roller then sued David
Copperfield again in federal court
this time for patent infringement.
And while motion to dismiss
the case was pending,
Roller filed an amended complaint,
alleging that Copperfield
and at least three other defendants
were engaged in a
conspiracy to murder him."
So in November, 2007,
the federal court again
dismissed Roller's claim
with prejudice and barred
the fictious litigant
from ever suing Copperfield again.
And here's a pro tip,
even if you had godly powers
that would not entitle you
to a patent on those godly powers,
which by the way would
expire after 17 years.
So I'm getting that this guy
has not put everything together,
but the court dismissed the
patent infringement claim
on the grounds that the patent actually
had not been granted
and thus roller had no patent rights
that could be infringed.
The court also found that
there were zero facts
to support the claim that Copperfield
was involved in a murderous
conspiracy against Roller.
And to add insult to injury in 2008,
the US patent and trademark office,
rejected Roller's patent writing,
"The specification has not described
how one of ordinary skill
and the art could make or use
the claimed godly powers."
And in a near identical
lawsuit filed in June, 2005,
Roller sued magician David
Blain for $2 million,
accusing the magician of
stealing Roller's godly powers
to perform his magic.
- Are you sure you
didn't buy a teddy bear?
- Yes, I'm sure I didn't.
- Teddy bear.
- [All] What the f?
- How did you.
- But the court dismissed that lawsuit
as well due to Roller's failure
to serve Mr. Blaine with the complaint.
And that's the thing about
trying to sue a magician,
they'll just disappear on you.
But that takes us to the
lawsuit of the Oregon man
who filed a billion dollar lawsuit
because Michael Jordan sorta
kind of maybe looks like him.
Now, as you probably know,
few people have embodied the greatness
of sports like basketball superstar
and popular meme template, Michael Jordan.
As the iconic basketball player
who earned six championship
rings with the Chicago Bulls
and nab to starting role
in the critically unclaimed "Space Jam."
Many have credited MJ as
the true goat of the NBA.
- It's just funny
'cause I don't remember
Jordan winning championships
with two different teams.
- Oh (beep).
- But contrary to the iconic
90s Gatorade commercial,
not everyone wanted to be like Mike,
especially not Portland,
Oregon resident, Alan Heckard,
who claimed that his life
had been completely ruined
after being mistaken for
the basketball champion
nearly every day for 15 years.
And argued to an actual court of law
that Michael Jordan and Nike
owed him nearly $1 billion
for his horrific
injustice because America.
In 2006, Heckard sued Michael
Jordan for 416 million,
arguing that the "Space Jam" star
was liable to Heckard for
emotional pain and suffering,
defamation and permanent injury.
Heckard acting as his own attorney,
I probably don't need to tell you,
alleged the following in the complaint;
"Whatever public functions he attends,
people are continually on
a daily basis harassing him
of looking like Michael Jordan.
These unpleasant feelings from the public
have trouble Heckard's nerves
and denied him the right
to a piece of mind."
#youhavenolegalright
to that piece of mind.
Now, Heckard also sued
Nike founder Phil Knight
for 416 million as well,
writing in the complaint that Knight,
"Contributed to turning
Michael Jordan into a legend
which forced Heckard to
change his appearance."
In interviews, Heckard
asserted the resemblance
to Michael Jordan was so powerful
that he would frequently draw crowds
of disappointed Jordan fans
whenever he went to church
or played basketball in the park.
"It's making life uncomfortable.
I'm constantly being harassed.
I should be able to enjoy my own life
but everywhere I go,
people tell me I look exactly like him."
Now, Heckard arguably
bears some resemblance
to MJ with a shaved head
and earring on his left ear
and similar conditioning from
playing amateur basketball.
But it should also be noted
that the 51 year old shuttle bus driver,
is eight years older than Michael Jordan.
And at six feet tall stands
a full six inches shorter
than the six time NBA champion.
And in this lawyer's opinion,
the gentleman from Portland
should be flattered
that anyone should mistake him
for Michael freaking Jordan
on the basketball court.
But Heckard did not find
the comparison complimentary at all.
Now, when asked how he arrived
at the damages amount of 416 million,
Heckard told the media,
"Well, you figure with my age
and you multiply that times seven
and then I turn around
and I figure that's what
it all boils down to."
Yeah, so that's not how
calculating damages works
or for that matter math.
But you don't need a
law degree to understand
why no lawyer agreed
to take such a patently
frivolous defamation case.
to assert a claim for defamation,
a plaintiff has to show that the defendant
made a false statement of fact
about the plaintiff to a third party
and this false statement
caused harm to the plaintiff.
Now, I probably don't need to tell you
that being repeatedly
confused for celebrity,
does not come close to being defamatory,
especially when there's no
evidence anyone did anything
to propagate the falsehood.
And it's not even a falsehood.
It's like when people say
that I look like Ryan Reynolds
or John Krasinski.
That's whatever the
opposite of defamation is.
Now when people say,
"I look like a Disney character
or a dad from a Pixar movie"
that is defamation.
- I don't know where this
disrespectful attitude came from.
- But Heckard doesn't
allege that Michael Jordan
or Nike falsely claimed that
Heckard is Michael Jordan.
So this is not defamation.
The complaint, much like
Heckard's damages calculation,
is essentially just the
underpants knowns of lawsuit.
- Phase one, collect underpants,
phase two, phase three, profit.
- I get it.
- Now, weeks later, Heckard
would spared the legal system
and further drama by
withdrawing the lawsuit
without explanation.
But the explanation is, it
was a frivolous lawsuit.
But that takes us to the firefighter
who was afraid to enter burning
buildings for fear of fire.
Now, when pollsters ask people
to name the most trusted
and admired professions,
you'll often find firefighters
at the top of the list.
Perhaps it's because they're like police
but they don't have a gun
with which to kill you.
But who doesn't love firefighters.
When they aren't saving cats from trees
or posing for hunky calendars,
firefighters are famous for
charging into burning buildings
to rescue those in harm's way.
But one Texas firefighter,
trying to claim that his fear
of charging into burning buildings,
was equivalent to illegal disability
and his removal from the front lines
was illegal disability discrimination.
A spoiler, he lost.
Enter Shayn Proler,
a Captain of the Houston Fire Department,
leader of a fire suppression crew
who had one teeny tiny problem.
He was afraid of fire,
for example, in 2004,
Proler arrived at the scene of a fire
and was unable to enter the building.
In 2006 during a house fire,
Proler was so frightened
that he was unable
to put on his firefighting
gear, take orders,
or even walk properly.
A doctor determined Proler
experienced a temporary memory loss
called global transient amnesia.
The city then Reassigned Proler
to Firefighting Training Academy.
Proler responded by filing
a successful administrative appeal,
after which he was returned
to the fire suppression crew.
And when the city took it to trial,
Proler filed a counterclaim,
arguing that his
reassignment violated laws
against disability discrimination.
Proler did not claim he was disabled,
just that the city of Houston
perceived him to be disabled,
making his reassignment a violation
of state and federal
anti-discrimination laws.
The jury agreed awarding
Proler $362,000 in damages.
The case was appealed all the way
to the Texas Supreme Court,
which throughout the jury verdict.
In the supreme court's opinion,
the court highlighted
that anti disability laws
do not protect every
person who wants a job,
but who lacks the mental, physical,
or experiential skill to
perform that particular job.
To illustrate the point that court argued
that lacking the skills to
play for the San Antonio Spurs,
does not mean a person is disabled.
Accordingly, the court concluded
that there was not a scintilla of evidence
that the fearful fire
captain was disabled.
Proler then argued that
even if he was not disabled,
the city perceived him as such
and thus is liable for taking
an adverse employment action,
namely by reassigning him based
on the perceived disability.
The court rejected this argument
that there was no basis for
classifying Proler's fear
as a disability.
Disability was defined as being regarded
as having a mental or physical impairment
that substantially limits at
least one major life activity.
And major life activity
refers to basic functions
like taking care of yourself,
walking, seeing, thinking,
and breathing.
Now under these definitions,
the court held that there was
no disability discrimination
against the fearful firemen
because, "Fighting fires is
not a major life activity."
The court also found that Proler's fear
of entering burning buildings
was not a disability to be
discriminated against noting,
"A reluctance to charge
into a burning building,
is not a mental impairment at all,
it's the normal human response.
Such a reluctance cannot be
characterized as an impairment,
much less an impairment
that substantially limits
a major life activity."
But if you're bitter over that lawsuit,
that's nothing compared to the bitterness
that a certain Austin resident felt
for a date who texted during a movie
and for whom he sued for $17.31.
Now, when it comes to finding love,
there's nothing more
exhilarating and nerve wracking
than the first date.
The excitement and promise
of a lasting connection,
tempered by the dread
that this will end in
disappointment like all others
or end in a lawsuit
against you for texting.
But that's exactly what happened
when Brandon Vezmer turned
to dispute over a date,
texting during a movie
into a legal dispute by
suing her for $17.31,
the cost of the movie.
Here's what happened, in May
of 2017, 37 year old Vezmer
took a 35 year old woman
who I'm just gonna call Nola Exit
to see "Guardian to the Galaxy Volume two"
in 3D in Austin, Texas.
Everything was going fine
until Miss Exit began to text.
The way that Vezmer put it,
"It was kind of a first date from hell.
This is like one of my
biggest pet peeves."
Yes, I'm sure that it
was just horrible for him
and this poor woman was
having the time of her life
and was being completely inconsiderate.
Now, after suggesting that
Ms. Exit step outside to text,
when she refused to stop,
she then left the theater
and never came back leaving
Vezmer to find his own ride
'cause yeah, that checks out.
Now, according to text messages posted
on his now defunct Twitter account,
Vezmer demanded that she
pay $17 for the movie ticket
and $4 for the slice of
pizza that he bought her
or else he would take her
to small claims court.
Ms. Exit likely assumed that
this was an empty threat.
I mean, who would haul someone
into small claims court
over a bogus $20 claim?
But apparently that person was none other
than her date Vezmer.
In his petition Vezmer alleged
that Ms. Exit used her phone to read
and send text messages
at least 10 to 20 times in 15 minutes.
In direct violation of
the theater's policy,
adversely affecting the viewing experience
of plaintiff and others.
Vezmer asked the court
for $17.31 in compensation
for defendant movie ticket,
dropping his initial $4
demand for the pizza.
He closed his petition in
dramatic fashion writing,
"While damages sought are modest
to the principle is important
as defendant's behavior is a
threat to civilized society."
So you can save civilized
society for $17.31?
That's kind of a bargain
when you put it that way.
Now the story immediately went viral
with The AV Club calling him a hero
and "Guardian's" Director, James Gunn,
cheekly suggesting that Vezmer's
date deserved jail time.
But not everyone was
cheering, "Let's go Brandon,"
especially the poor woman
who went on this date.
When the Austin American
statesman informed her
about the lawsuit, she replied,
"Oh my God, this is crazy."
She then disputed Vezmer's claim
that she texted 10 to 15 times,
saying she only sent two texts to a friend
in a fight with her boyfriend
and kept her phone low to
ensure no one was disturbed.
She then issued a statement
to a local news station,
"I did have a very brief date with Brandon
that I chose to end prematurely.
His behavior made me
extremely uncomfortable
and I felt I needed to remove myself
from the situation for my own safety.
He has escalated situation far past
what any mentally healthy person would.
I feel sorry that I hurt
his feelings badly enough
that he felt he needed
to commit so much time
and effort into seeking revenge.
I hope one day he can move past this
and find peace in his life."
Yeah, why am I not surprised
that this guy completely
misread the situation?
I guess it might have been a tip off
that he filed a lawsuit
that had no legal merit
whatsoever purely out of spite.
I guess that, yeah,
that probably should have
tipped me off to that.
Now this matter was
finally settled in a sense,
thanks to Inside Edition
who arranged for the pair
to meet outside the original movie theater
because that worked the first time.
She ended up paying this
guy $17.31 telling him,
"The date just didn't work out.
Just leave this alone."
And while Vezmer did drop the suit,
he stands by his conduct.
- Count it right, just to
make sure it's all here.
10, 15, 16, 17, 31 cents.
- And Vezmer issued a statement
that he wanted people to,
"Treat other people with
respect and dignity."
Exactly the kind of respect and dignity
that is not commensurate with
filing a bull (beep) lawsuit
out of revenge, sorry Brandon.
- It's settled.
(upbeat music)
- Now, if you'd like to see
even more dumb criminals
and terrible lawyers,
check out my new exclusive
video "Too Hot for YouTube."
But I'm sorry to tell you,
it's too hot for YouTube.
So to see that exclusive video,
you'll have to head over
to today's sponsors,
Nebula and Curiosity Stream,
because on Nebula, my
videos always come out early
with zero ads,
and I release exclusive
content all the time,
like an entire video about legal stories
that are not safe for work
and too hot for YouTube,"
as well as exclusive videos
like "Things People Misunderstand
About The Constitution,
Why NFTs Are Bad For Creators."
And my first full length documentary,
"Bad Law Words Good" and tons
more, all exclusive to Nebula.
And all of this exclusive content
is available only on Nebula,
which you get for free
with Curiosity Stream.
Because Nebula is creator
owned and creator operated,
there's new exclusive content
released multiple times every day.
And by the way,
we've been developing Nebula like crazy.
Nebula now has apps for
iOS, Android, Apple TV,
Roku, Fire TV, and Android TV,
And it was recently nominated
for its first Stream Award.
My fellow creators and I
really care about Nebula
and we're thrilled to be
partnering with Curiosity Stream
because they're the go-to source
for the best documentaries
and long form educational
content on the internet.
And they even have an
entire section devoted
to unsolved mysteries in crimes.
So if you like my videos,
you'll love the thousands of
titles on Curiosity Stream.
Now, the best way to get access to Nebula
and all of this incredible content,
is through the amazing Curiosity
Stream, Nebula bundle deal
with this current sales price
of less than $15 per year
to get full access to both sites.
And to be clear that Nebulous
subscription is on a trial.
It's free for as long as you're
a Curiosity Stream member.
There just isn't a
better deal in streaming
where you get access to
two great streaming sites
with content that you'll
actually watch and enjoy,
all for less than $15 per year
at the current sales price.
So sign up now by clicking on the button
that's on screen right now,
or you can click on the link
that's down below in the description.
It's a great way to
support educational content
and get tons of exclusive
content that you'll love.
So click on the link below right now
and after that, click on
this playlist over here
for more Legal Eagle,
or I'll see you in court.